hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich muss heute einen
geburtstagskuchen für zwei fußball
verrückte jungs machen und deswegen habe
ich gedacht ich muss was ganz schnell
das machen weil ich nicht so viel zeit
habe und habe mich dazu entschlossen
meinen fußball form zu benutzen und es
hat auch ganz gut gepasst denn einige
von euch haben dir schon und wussten
aber nicht was wenn kuchen die es da
drin backen können
deswegen werde ich hier heute einen
fußball kuchen backen und eine
zuschauerin
das fand ich ganz super hat mich darauf
hingewiesen sie hat die frau bei mir
bestellt und hat gesagt dass sie daraus
auch zum beispiel eine schildkröte
machen könnte
oder zb auch ein marienkäfer und auf die
idee bin ich bisher gar nicht gekommen
also ich hatte den ja benutzt für meinen
osterkorb um den darüber zu flechten und
dachte dann okay fußball wm kommt dann
auch gut aber auf die idee mit der
schildkröte oder mit dem käfer bin ich
auch nicht gekommen
und das finde ich echt klasse ich habe
mich jetzt dazu entschlossen einen ganz
einfachen rührteig zu machen
ich werde ein bisschen zitronenaroma
hinzufügen in form von zitronenschale
aber ihr könnt einfach dieses
grundrezept vom rührteig nehmen und zum
beispiel auch eine schoko teig machen
und so weiter den kuchen könnte auch
beliebig füllen aber das werde ich jetzt
nicht machen
und wer jetzt einfach mal direkt in die
küche gehen und dann starten
ihr braucht 250 g weiche butter 250
gramm zucker sechs eier
die habe ich schon getrennt 250 gramm
mehl
ein esslöffel zitronenschale eine
packung backpulver und eine prise salz
zuerst gibt jetzt das eiweiß in die
schüssel und lebte prise salz mit dazu
das müsst ihr auch direkt mit dazu geben
damit die eiweiß struktur schnell
zerstört wird und das wird ganz schön
steif geschlagen
danach könnt ihr dann die hälfte von dem
zucker hinzufügen
das hilft dann einfach dass es bei
schnee später nicht flockt und man es
schön unter heben kann
wenn dann die eismasse fertig ist könnt
ihr sie zur seite stellen und bereits
die wahre mutter in die nächste
rührschüssel geben und die mit dem
restlichen zucker verrühren
danach kommen noch die eigelbe mit dazu
und es wird sogar richtig schönen
glatten masse verrührt zum schluss
könnte jetzt noch die restlichen zutaten
hinzufügen
hier könnte zum beispiel auch vanille
aroma benutzen oder etwas mürrisch
kakaopulver ersetzen
und dann könnt ihr das ganze noch etwas
mit zitronensaft abschmecken und wenn
die masse zu fest ist gerne auch noch
etwas milch hinzufügen
jetzt wird die schneemasse eben drei
portionen unter den teig gehoben und
dann ist der teig auch schon fertig
dieser darf dann in die gefettete und
mit mehl bestäubte form gefüllt werden
ihr seht jetzt auch hier wie hoch der
teig eingefüllt wird der teig wird dann
bei 175 grad für etwa 35 bis 40 minuten
gebacken
das kommt natürlich auf euren ofen
treffer an und ihr solltet auf jeden
fall die stäbchen proben machen
danach könnt ihr den kuchen aus dem ofen
herausnehmen in ganz kurz abkühlen
lassen und ihn dann auf ein abkühlen
gitter stürzen und die form lässt sich
ganz einfach entfernen wenn ihr einfach
etwas an der oberfläche klopft dann
fällt der kuchen schon von alleine raus
ich denke jetzt noch mit einem tuch ab
und lass ihn vollständig abkühlen
ihr könnt jetzt hier ganz toll erkennen
wie schön weich und blogger der kuchen
ist und auch wie toll man hier die form
schon erkennen kann also mit den sechs
ecken und fünf ecken und das brauchen
wir natürlich auch später wenn wir dann
den kuchen mit von dann überziehen
wollen
hier habe ich jetzt etwas zitronensaft
und werte etwas aprikosenmarmelade damit
verrühren
ich nehme die aprikosenmarmelade ohne
stückchen und werde dann den kuchen so
ein bisschen damit trinken damit er
etwas feuchter bleibt und natürlich auch
etwas geschmack bekommt und ich brauche
natürlich auch eine grundlage für meinen
fondant später und möchte jetzt nicht
mit gas oder so arbeiten sondern ein
ganz leichtes zitronenaroma hinzufügen
und einfach die marmelade
als bindemittel zwischen kuchen und
fondant benutzen
anschließend werde ich den kuchen
einfach auf eine holzplatte geben ihr
könnt natürlich auch auf eine
tortenplatte setzen und dann werde ich
ihn mit weißem fondant eindecken
ich habe meine hände mit palmen
eingefettet und habe den von dort ganz
gut durchgeknetet ich habe etwa 400 bis
500 gramm fondant verwendet und möchte
ihn jetzt so dünn ausrollen dass ich
später eben noch die konturen von dem
kuchen sehen kann und außerdem wollten
von dort sehr dünn ausrollen damit er
einfach nicht zu süß auf der torte drauf
ist und man die muster auf der fussball
traute richtig gut erkennen kann
zum ausrollen verwende ich immer gerne
becker stärke und meinen silikon aus
wollstoff damit klappt es wunderbar und
nachdem ich die richtige größe erreicht
hatte konnte ich den von dort noch ein
bisschen zurecht schneiden die reste
könnt ihr natürlich immer wieder weiter
verwenden
ihr müsst nur aufpassen dass er sie
nicht verschmutzt der von dann ist jetzt
bei mir so dünn dass ich sogar die
schrift von das silikon martin durch
sehen kann das heißt für mich ist dünn
genug und ich kann ihn auf die torte
draufsetzen mit meinen händen streiche
ich ihnen jetzt von oben nach unten
glatt und weiter damit den abschluss
einfach wegschneiden und auch diesen
fondant wieder einpacken
man kann die formen des fußballs richtig
toll erkennen
dennoch werde ich die formen jetzt mit
meinem modell ihr werkzeug schön
nachfahren damit die muster richtig
deutlich zu erkennen sind
ich möchte keine normalen schwarz weißen
fußball machen sondern ich habe mich
dazu entschlossen einen ganz besonderen
fußball zu machen und zwar gibt es ja
alle vier jahre für die wm einen neuen
fußball von adidas und ich hab jetzt
gedacht ich mache diesen passus richtig
ausgebrochen
und deswegen wollte jetzt auf dieses
schwarz-weiß verzichten und stattdessen
eben diesen bazooka zeichnen
ich hoffe das gelingt mir auch die
vorlage und die ich mir leider schon
eingerissen und anhand von der vorlage
möchte ich dann versuchen den ball
einfach ein zu zeichnen und zu malen
ich habe mich übrigens dazu entschlossen
nur eine halbkugel zu backen und keine
gesamte kugel
wenn ihr aber natürlich eine gesamte
kugel machen wollt müsst ihr den teig
jetzt einfach mal 2
und könnt dann die beiden hälften mit
etwas marmelade oder kanals oder
irgendeiner anderen creme einfach
zusammenfügen und habe dann eine
komplette kugel
ich habe jetzt darauf verzichtet einfach
weil mir das jetzt zu zeitaufwendig war
und weil ich einfach eine einfachen
kuchen machen wollte so dass ihn eben
auch jeder nachmachen kann und man gut
abschneiden kann wenn ich die torte
jetzt mit schwarz und weiß dekorieren
wollte würde ich jetzt meine schwarze
passten farbe nehmen und einfach das
kleine fünfeck in der mitte anmahnen und
die sechsecke außenrum freilassen und so
müsst ihr dann weiter fortfahren immer
das kleine fünfmal die sechsecke die
drum herum liegen frei lassen und so
könnt ihr dann die komplette torte
bemalen
ich habe mich ja jetzt für die andere
methode entschieden und habe jetzt
einfach meine lebensmittel stifter
verwendet um die konturen vor zu
zeichnen
anschließend habe ich mir das muster
group ausgezeichnet
und dann meine pulver farben mit etwas
alkohol vermischt und diese dann zum
bepinseln genommen und dann die
komplette torte damit bemalt der alkohol
hat den vorteil dass er sofort auf der
torte trocknet und auch gleich verfliegt
und die farben dann schön fest bleiben
auch wischfest ihr könnt auch etwas pany
verwenden und dies natürlich vorher
etwas erwärmung damit es flüssig wird
und damit auch die farben vermischen
hier habt ihr allerdings das problem
dass die farben nicht wischfest sind
sondern auch zum beispiel durch wärme
wieder feucht werden und dann eben auch
verwischen können
ihr könnt die farben aber auch mit etwas
zitronensaft vermischen
da ist es einfach so dass die farben da
nicht so schnell auf der torte trocknen
und etwas länger brauchen als alkohol
ich werde allerdings auch ein einzelnes
video dazu machen mit welchen farben man
torten gut bemalen kann und was die
besten methoden dafür sind
nachdem ich die torte dann fertig
angemalt hatte habe ich einen
großartigen tag gestellt um drumherum
noch etwas gras außen rum zu spritzen
dafür habe ich eine packung butter
zucker verwendet also 250 gramm
diese mit drei esslöffeln eiweißpulver
vermischt und dann sechs esslöffel
wasser hinzugefügt und das ganze mit
grünen zu einem richtig schönen satten
grün vermischt mit der gras thüle konnte
ich dann so ringsherum das gras herum
spritzen
so sieht der kuchen jetzt fertige aus
also meine fertige torte und hätte ich
jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr zeit gehabt
hätte ich hier noch eine kleine
anzeigentafel gebastelt und zwar so wie
im stadion eben auch mit 30 drauf mit
den namen drauf das ist nämlich für eine
torte für zwillinge und ich werde jetzt
aber so lassen weil ich jetzt drei
stunden in der küche stand und wirklich
keine zeit mehr hat schon zu spät bin
mein mann schon den kopf schüttelt und
deswegen werde ich jetzt die torte
einpacken
nächste woche werde ich dann hoffentlich
endlich in meiner eigenen küche stehen
also ich habe noch ein rezept
da sich im küchenstudio gemacht habe und
dieses rezept gibt es auch auf meinem
blog auf www cell ist orten welt.de und
ich werde gehen
bis bald wenn ihr noch weitere wm
rezepte sucht könnte er meine trikot
torte anschauen oder auch einfach die wm
cup cakes nachmachen oder die leckere
und superfrucht die gwm tat
klickt einfach auf eines der folgenden
bilder und ihr gelangt direkt zum video